online gamer Aiden Jackson is no
stranger to playing opponents from
across the globe but rarely does he
expect one to save his life in the real
world that is exactly what happened when
a friend he was playing 5,000 miles away
in Texas recognized something was wrong
vintage place hi I'm currently in a call
with my friend he had a seizure and he's
not responding anymore
I was in witness Chester sorry I'm
shaking while the police and ambulance
were dispatched Aiden's parents were
downstairs unaware of the drama
unfolding well first we knew there was
two police cars arrived out front
flashing lights I just had a look
thinking that they were going elsewhere
and then they started to run up our path
and they said I had a call on responsive
mail at the address I we said oh not
called anyone is that no the calls come
from America a possible seizure so then
that made me think Aiden so I just run
up the stairs found aid and he was
really disorientated and not really with
it at all Aiden Saviour was 20 year old
diella thora you could hear that he was
in trouble I've just gotten up from a
computer to go and sit down on bed I
felt a little funny so I turned my mic
around so she could still hear me and
then next thing I knew I was waking up
with police summer parents in a room and
saying that I just had a seizure I had
no idea what was going on while Aidan is
still having tests to figure out what's
wrong he has managed to thank dear when
I was in hospital and managed to get
ahold of mom's iPad so I could still
talk to her let her know there was okay
and in fact at least maybe five ten
times for it so yeah I mean thank her
every time is here
Aiden is back online gaming but mum now
insists the bedroom door stays open Dan
Whitehead Sky News in Widnes Cheshire